heute geht es ja heute der vorsitzende
adr spricht hier als stellvertretender
fraktionschef der neuen fraktion
identität und demokratie in der unter
anderem die italienische lega und die
französischen freunde von madame lippen
organisiert sind präsidenten der
europäischen kommission ist von großer
bedeutung für die union und ihre
mitgliedstaaten darum wie diese
entscheidung mit großer sorgfalt
getroffen seien nur eine person höchste
eignung kann für diese position infrage
kommen frau ministerin von der leyen
bei allem respekt vor ihrer person wir
von der fraktion identität und
demokratie sind nach sorgfältiger
prüfung der meinung dass sie den
ansprüchen die an dieses amt zu stellen
sind nicht gewachsen sind
ich möchte dass kurz begründen zunächst
haben wir deutschen mit ihrer art der
amtsführung und politik gestaltung
unserer ganz eigenen erfahrungen
wir haben sie im laufe der jahre in
deutschland als familienministerin als
ministerin für arbeit und soziales
schließlich als ministerin der
verteidigung erlebt in keinem dieser
ämter sind sie ihre aufgabe dem wohle
des deutschen volkes zu dienen
zufriedenstellend gerecht geworden ich
erspare ihnen und dem auditorium hier
eine explizite auflistung ihres
scheiterns sie haben unsere truppe
kaputtgespart sie ist sie ist heute
miserabel wie nie ausgestattet und
praktisch nicht verteidigungs fähig ist
wird ein großes aufatmen in der
bundeswehr geben wenn sie morgen
ungeachtet des ausgangs des heutigen
tages ihr amt als
verteidigungsministerin niederlegen
ein kompletter neustart in praktisch
allen bereichen wird hier vonnöten sein
nun haben gerade deutsche regierung in
früheren zeiten oft missliebig gewordene
politiker auf brüsseler posten
untergebracht das aber kann der anspruch
hier und heute wohl nicht mehr sein
nichts spricht aus unserer sicht dafür
dass sie die position der
kommissionspräsident schafft besser
ausfallen würden als ihre vorherigen
ämter ihre vorstellungstour durch das
haus und seine fraktion ihre lange liste
an wolkigen versprechungen von diesem
und jenem und meist zugleich auch von
seinem gegenteil je nachdem wo sie
gerade vorstellig wurden viele ja
beileibe nicht nur uns kritisch auf den
linken und liberalen versichern sie am
artikels
im verfahren gegen polen und ungarn
strikt festhalten zu wollen in der
fraktion sagen sie milde ruhe und
toleranz bei der verteilung von
migranten zu
diese widersprüche sind eklatant und
heute servieren sie hier einen schier
unglaublichen strauß an wohlklingenden
schlagwörtern für alle und jeden soll
etwas dabei sein was sie gerne hören
sie legen hier in ihrer bewerbungstour
ein klassisches mainstream politiker
verhalten an den tag machen leere
versprechungen spielen eine art von
jekyll and hyde mit den fraktionen in
der banken hoffnung am ende irgendwie
genug stimmen für ihre wahl generieren
zu können
ihr problem bei alledem ist ihnen fehlt
jede überzeugende vision einer modernen
einer den menschen der union wirklich
dienenden einer sich klub und sinnvoll
auf ihre kernaufgaben beschränkenden
union der vaterländer im gegenteil sie
versprechen hier noch mehr
zentralisierung noch mehr besteuerung
noch mehr bevormundung noch mehr
kompetenz anmaßung und eben sich
komplett widersprechen die inhalte sie
sind noch ganz im alten denken beachtet
spüren dass aber offenkundig nicht von
den fragen die ich ihnen vergangene
woche in der konferenz auf präsident für
meine fraktion gestellt habe haben die
zwei erst gar nicht beantwortet und die
dritte hochgradig unbefriedigend und von
der idee fraktion können sie mit einer
solchen sozialistischen anbiederung
performance wir heute hier vorgetragen
nicht überzeugen wir werden besser als
gegen sie stimmen
[Applaus]